i'm very appreciative that you could do
this interview because we are on
opposite ends of the united states and i
also don't take it for granted because i
know that you are not a tech
savvy person you are not comfortable
with technology is that true
absolutely somebody had to set this all
up for me i
i don't have a cell phone you wanna have
a cell phone
no i don't have a computer i've never
sent
a text or an email or how do you
make a phone call let's say you're on a
movie set and you want to make a phone
call
to say to me to your old friend conan
o'brien how would you do it
well here at home i have a land mine a
land line
i hope you don't have a land mine that a
landline that was here when i
when i when i moved in uh same number
and uh when i on a set sometimes they
give me a cell phone
but it's not for me it's so they can
reach me
that's amazing i'm i think so many of us
have become so dependent on ours i'm
fascinated by the idea that you don't
have
uh access even to a computer do you ever
have you ever googled yourself on a
computer i have not
my wife has has a computer and she knows
about these things and
uh you know that pretty much takes care
of it for me
it's your wife funny we'll tell you
you know what they're saying about you
on the internet if you needed to even
know that
she says don't look
[Laughter]
do you um have you ever looked at uh
google earth that's something that i'm
not very
tech savvy but i love google earth
sometimes i like to go on and just look
at my
where i live just to see you ever done
that yes you know
in the old days on movie sets actors
would sit around
uh between setups and takes
and they would play cards or they'd read
a book and now of course they all have
their cell phones and i said to a friend
of mine
could you google my house and it was
really amazing
i could see you know lawn chairs and
the car in the driveway it's really
fantastic you know
i hope it was your car yeah that's what
they say watch out for those uh
strange cars yeah uh uh so that's
i'm glad that you have some familiarity
with it
if you're not getting if you're not on
the internet do you get
mail then let's say fans want to write
you letters they want to write to
the great christopher walken they want
to write do you get fan mail like
through the us postal system
yes what kind of stuff do you do you
read those letters you read any of them
i do and uh it's
it's uh that's a tricky thing because
you have to be careful about
acknowledging sometimes i get
strange things not too strange
but just odd and uh of course you know
if you answer somebody you confirm that
they know where you
are so yeah you got to be careful about
that careful
do you um get requests i sometimes get
requests in the mail
that are strange strange requests
yeah well you know just so ordinary come
to my wedding
you know i'm in arizona you know
[Music]
do this do that but did you ever get
requests from money
sure absolutely
because i sent you one
i asked you for eight hundred dollars i
never heard back well you did get it
because otherwise i
it was money misspent
[Laughter]
i sent it to you immediately
okay well then i just must have
misplaced it i occasionally
think of you know i should write
christopher walken and see if i could
get some money and just to see what
happens
and uh i put the cash in the envelope so
maybe somebody took it